Hmm,
roughly 95 percent of the lyrics in pop
culture or about mating or there about
mating rituals.
There are about courtship rituals and
you as a person who is white,
the meeting has been upgraded by the
best and now includes,
okay.
God knows what it was trying to tell us.
So at any rate,
um,
you have just emerged from childhood,
your hormones,
your sexual hormones and begun to act
girls as young as 11 can become pregnant
already and you were obsessed with
finding your place in the world and
finding a mate and courtship rituals
mean an awful lot to you there about to
what they're there,
what you were about to embark on for the
next 10 years of your life at least.
Um,
and so this obsession with courtship
rituals with mating and dating and
breaking up and,
and be trail and all of that kind of
stuff makes,
makes absolute sense.
Right?
Exactly.
Well,
and the thing is music frames that too
because it gives you something that's in
common with your potential mate.
And it also gives you a set of rather,
I wouldn't say stereotyped activities,
but at least predictable activities that
are associated with courtship and made
again,
so that would be going to concerts and
going to movies which are heavily
musically influenced and dancing and,
and even discussing your,
your shared immersement in whatever that
subculture happens to be.
Right.
And my guess is that at some point music
provokes oxytocin because oxytocin is
the ultimate bonding hormone and music
is a bath in the sense of human
belonging in the field.
But even if you're alone and you're
listening to Pandora or spotify all by
yourself,
it feeds you social,
bread and meat.
And in the,
in the nervous system,
the central nervous system,
everything boils down to inhibition or
excitation.
There is a hormone of excitation and
it's glutamate is a hormone of
inhibition,
and that's the Gaba and oxytocin feeds
down into the Gaba system.
The system that keeps you calm down.
Basically,
it gives you a sense of peace.